- Did anybody else get a bear
hug from Batman? (laughs)
- No but, ah man, we were three weeks into
shooting and I didn't have no lines,
we were just doing all
of the basketball stuff.
So when we had the scene
where he introduces himself
as the coach, I was so happy, I'm like
"I finally get to speak, finally!"
And so, I remember when I
got ready to say my lines
and this guy cuts my line off,
and so
(Kelly laughs)
I let it slide, y'know what I'm saying?
(audience laughs)
- I let Ben Affleck slide. (laughs)
- Left the heater in the back, you know.
- Oh, you are so bold.
- No, he didn't let anything
slide, tell them the story.
- I didn't 'cause he did it
one more time and I was like,
"Oh no, I'm not taking
this, Ben Affleck, who?"
(audience laughs)
And so, I just remember
I was talking with Melvin
and the group, I said "I'm
about to tell Ben Affleck off"
and they were like,
- [Kelly] Get off my line!
- And they were like, "you're
crazy, don't do that,"
and I ran over and I sprinted,
and I hit him right on
the chest I was like,
"Hey man, you're stepping on
my lines, what's up with that?"
You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] I'm proud of that,
I've been waiting a minute.
- I told him, "Ben
Affleck, you're Ben Affleck
you're in this movie,
you've got all the lines,
I don't got that many lines,
you know what I mean?"
(audience laughter)
I need all the chances I can
get, and I had the script
and I was telling him the line, oh my god.
- This story has grown, I mean.
(audience laughter)
- I punched him in the face.
- The truth is I stepped on his line once,
his line was "what," (laughter)
and I looked past it.
I didn't even think about
it, and then he gave the
(mumbling)
(laughter)
What's going on?
"that's my line you're stepping on."
- Hey! (laughter) don't
make me sound like that.
- Yo, what, that's my line!
I have to say, I didn't
look at the other guys,
and they were all like (grimaces).
- It was the same clip that
they showed before we came out,
he was spitting facts, he cut that off.
- I did respect that, I was like,
"this guy is not gonna let any
(mumbles) take his
line, my line is "what!"
I'm gonna say my line.
- That's my favorite, that's so bold!